This is like the first time my art has ever
been in a gallery so this is a pretty
cool experience coming in as a freshmen
like I didn't imagine my art would be
in the student center. That was
really cool and it was also just like
really nice to see a lot of
different artists from like
there's like grad students in this
program, there's undergrad students, like this whole
wide range of different people with
different experiences and it just all comes
together in one gallery.
The opportunity to experience new forms of expression
is a really valuable experience for
undergraduates and graduates and I'm really
glad that the art scholars gives us that
opportunity
What's most rewarding for me is seeing the
new Wiesner gallery because I have had
art displayed here in the old one and
the new one is just so much better it
feels like an art gallery now and that's
really exciting. So this is I think much
nicer to have here because it does feel
more like a space that is for art.